welcome to this video five-minute
gimmick against Moscow wow this is some
weird stuff scene I'm an anesthesia
anesthesiologist tough to talk to
pronounce ok maybe abalone yes we gotta
be known him so he at least plays
openings that don't very fit very much
with this job nothing nothing too boring
um really can go a six-year remarkable
on e4 what happens Castle c5 maybe that
surprises me that you can afford that
move a six-top bishops is 7 immediately
okay let's let's start him maybe castles
now I mean e5 as a big threat zone so
Bishop d3 movie 5 rupee eight is
certainly a bit a bit a bit early okay
yeah this opening is called the snake
been only because of the snake like
Bishop maneuver it's got a slightly
dodgy reputation not not being totally
and sound but also not being totally
correct I wonder if I have something
something something direct here like a
five maybe
no it certainly has some compensation
let's try that it's I it's interesting
to to play at least go here play for the
pens pieria development not sure that
this is a one not one hundred percent
correct sacrifice but it is certainly
interesting this is so the point really
wide wants to make sure that the c8
bishop is not so easily playing can now
you can try that but this is of course
giving me yet another temple and really
active pieces okay so what now you will
play Bishop to be seven should I blame
the Bishop g5 this Knight e5 this won't
won't be that great okay this was my
original idea anyway putting this
pressure on h7 and maybe threatening 95
am now trying to distract the night from
f6 and therefore intend to find the
pressure on age 795 is I think a serious
move him
hmm I won't know maybe maybe night
before could be a move see far hmm ok at
least 95 is probably not fatal now it
should f5 p.m. very interesting very
interesting stuff Bishop f5 there might
be 94 m yeah if i go to be one my rooks
are not connected this is a this is a
problem should have 590 form
against I can just play for my
development by crook you want or
something but I'm not sure that it is
really a very powerful giving up the
bishop seems wrong okay maybe I will
treat this rom on one minute 35 I
managed again to get myself into
big-time pressure I mean blacks position
is really problematic it's pretty clear
but my time also is okay rook age 5 SS
defensive IDM bishop age 7 mm it's not
helping ok well this is a serious move
mm okay only way to prevent rogue age 5
very directly Queen f8 I take f6 ok now
is going for Knight f3 maybe hmm ok can
i play rupee one time morning ok
he moves the the rook and maybe have 95
night for the screen age seven Queen f8
mate there's probably something that
refutes my my setup him it just feels
very shaky but I have 56 seconds it will
be six for example but I'm not not
really maybe I take there's a double
check double check is always always a
bit tricky
but I don't see really a direct
refutation of my play I don't see it
then maybe is something but I don't see
it at the moment Rock g5 something like
that I can play gt5 you not sure if it's
the best move but maybe 94 is also
strong 94 Bishop before and how would I
seem home with f5 menu okay Roxy five
then maybe g5 check check now this is at
least forcing a draw I think the problem
is that i absolutely no time Keane e8
Queen age 8 is winning is there some way
to win this g5 now that's unfortunately
Bishop d7 now this is the problem check
came the check again this is some way to
play for win him I don't see Jack I
really don't see it
g5 forgave tunes not working maybe g5 is
winning as I know I don't know really I
don't I cannot calculate in 19 seconds
no yeah I think white is winning but I
hates the draw okay if the computer will
tell it right away I had the hunch that
there might be something but it does not
seem to be the case and maybe there was
something before it it was very tricky
okay of course I got myself into huge
tantowel as soaked as usual okay and
Bishop h6 it seems is not correct yeah
around here white certainly has a nice
compensation that that's clear but how
much it is is a different thing computer
wants to play Bishop g5 him this I
didn't really take into account that
much but it's a it's a valid ID n this
is some the suggestion here by stock
fish with white being a somewhat better
yeah it's a very nice compensation and
my pieces are very well positioned and
black is somewhat uncoordinated nothing
decisive though okay I needed to play at
some point and here was the next
difficult question to answer this was
also most but I didn't want to really
after 90 form I didn't want this
exchange maybe this is the wrong wrong
impression something like this is
interesting I mean even this here with
with something like Bishop g5 can be a
can be played certainly
it was interesting computer does not
like it but it was an interesting option
yeah gee I simply felt okay now or never
but it's not working objectively the
computer tells me rookie 5 yeah now okay
I needed to do something g 494 and like
is winning here according to the machine
with in fact queen bee six young twin B
6 p-6 p 6 p-6 mmm I don't see it yet I
all ready don't why is this winning
exactly I night f5 of course yeah night
f5 who know another five a totally over
I was only looking at those double
checks they look so tempting but they
don't lead to anything but of course
that's just picking up the Queen yeah
then queen bee six is quite clearly
winning because well this is the big
threat and I don't even have a check in
here so I'm just lost okay Queen B 6
would've won the game jack and this
seems to be wrong check yeah seems I
cannot play for when after g5 he's got
this check him and we should just having
just for my maid oh sorry here the
computer actually he prefers to allow d6
interestingly enough with Queen DS Queen
f3 Queen f.3d six rook 831 with a good
position for Wyatt according to the
engine who interesting yeah mainly
because Queen g3 and Bishop d6 can very
often Lee to UM to regain of this pawn
possible yeah this was lucky at the end
but at least it was a good fighting game
thanks for watching